foreign
Center thought I'd be here either
I'll probably be locked up in
in prison if you do what you love doing
and you do it well
then everything should sort of fall into
place especially if you're coming up
with something from nothing which is
presumably what we all do in the
creative department is that why I'm
selling a handful of nothing and and
hoping to come through with some some
results even if you don't know quite
what it is that you want to achieve that
if you just keep cracking on towards it
anyway that you know if you do what you
love doing I think as human beings by
Nature as a species we're awful
we have to constantly ask ourselves the
uncomfortable questions
I mean it is the world
better for me having been in it
and if the last few years have taught me
anything it's uh is that rather than
change the world to better suit our
needs how
how can we change ourselves to better
suit
the world that we all live in and if one
is passionate and committed in the noble
pursuit of Excellence within their
chosen field be that the Arts technology
science humanitarianism conservationism
uh then I would say
one has a moral obligation
and an ethical Duty
to be of service and to always strive to
be part of the solution not the problem
after all it's a world that our children
would inherit
that's worth being a part of
that speaks to me
what scares you everything not being in
control not knowing anticipation like
waiting for something to go wrong
I'm an addict and alcoholic so I have my
ups and downs yeah thank you I have a
compassion for certain uh an
understanding of uh of certain erratic
and unpredictable Behavior it doesn't
always manifest yourself and environment
yeah yeah um but as an artist as well I
think it does you know within the
creative arts you can create things or
you can destroy things can't you I
always take myself really seriously so I
I beat myself up pretty badly the sort
of thing um abstract when um about
issues that cause fear or bother to get
in the way of doing it you know getting
into work doing my job or anything or
gaming world with life and where did you
think that came from for you I don't
know I don't know I think my my personal
issues to do with you know alcoholism or
anything like that I can't remember to
be honest because a lot of it's blackout
isn't it so you would black out of
course and this was what alcohol yeah
and everything else everything else
all the different substances available
yeah
most of them everything wow it's lucky
you're still here yes and I'm very
grateful to be here you know it's uh
it's no joke
um and I'll put myself right out there
for the risk of it and I will fail and
it's okay to fail in fact you learn more
from failing and humiliation in my game
than than any than any other that I know
um and actually that seems to be quite
similar across the board in most
Professionals for the people that I've
met so it's good to fail it's not
embarrassing and humiliation is your
friend I don't know if it's nature or
nurture or where it came from it's just
it just is and it's what I have and I
have to deal with it on a daily basis
and do you feel you're winning uh yeah
today is a very very good day
thoughtfully examine
the roles we play and how to be well how
to best be of use and to be of service
in a noble pursuit to make the world a
better place
I believe that Perfection is
unattainable
but that doesn't stop us trying
and we should constantly be evolving
redefining refining predicting analyzing
adapting
to whatever the world throws at us you
know and and in harmony with that world
passion
action
Noble intention
creates progress
passion creates progress